we may not be governed except by our
consent and we don't give it no
governing all government is illegitimate
except with that and of course it
follows from that that in the practical
operation of the government since
unanimity is impossible majority rule
and of course in a college in a proper
college if you disagree somebody's wrong
we're here to find out who's wrong and
who's right
well we always disagree how we ever
gonna figure it out right but yeah so
there's gonna be voting and there's
gonna be disagreement and we're not
gonna reach unanimity why is the
majority the right thing
it seems like it's more probable that
more people since it's not a mob at that
time because they're voting on something
in a Republican fashion mm-hmm that they
would have considered it in a way that
would refine their opinions mmm that's
really novel I don't think it's true all
men are created equal you got 300 people
160 want to do a and 140 you want to do
not a if you do what the hundred and
forty says you've got yourself an
aristocracy right in other words the
majority of equals souls has to stand in
for the unanimous consent right and in
anything not fundamental or anything
that involves the ongoing operation of
the government that's what you need see
so the point is you're gonna have
majorities rule you're gonna have
representation and that gives rise to
something new and Madison says that it's
never happened before it's unique the
sovereign is the people as expressed by
what I'll introduce a new phrase that
Abraham Lincoln's liked the people as
they express their wealth through their
constitutional majority is the only true
sovereign of a free people and so that's
where sovereignty is that's where
the right to say the legitimate title to
rule is but those people the sovereign
are entirely excluded from the operation
of the government do you see now how the
first check on the government is that we
must consent but the second check on the
government is that we who have the power
to consent do not run the government and
that second check is a check on us in
the argument between the Federalists and
the anti-federalists the
anti-federalists argue a lot that that
local is more trustworthy and they got
their say extensively right because for
most of American history but not lately
local government did most everything the
federal government is the most powerful
of our governments but it's a government
of enumerated powers right and so
limited in what it can do supreme and
what it can do limited in what it can do
right but the Federalists counter is not
central is better and it's certainly
true that the constitutional government
was called the Constitutional Convention
was called to make a more powerful
government at the center the Federalist
answer is that every human exercise of
power must be restrained by reason and
there are constitutional forms that have
to be implemented that can help bring
that out and if the first constitutional
form is representation the method by
which we give our ongoing consent the
second is the separation between
sovereignty and power